foreign
[Music]
against the 23.50 okay so this is
gonna be a serious game
let's go for D4
let's go for D4 and you know what I feel
like playing a jabala London we're
playing a very serious opponent so I'm
going to play something that I
personally am comfortable with which is
the jibaba London and at this level I
think it's still
quite effective and not as well known
you might remember that we have had one
jababa London in the speedrun
which was pretty successful
um I was better out of the opening let's
see how this one turns out A6 so A6 is a
first tier line black has maybe three or
four
uh legitimate ways to meet the move
Bishop F4 there's C5 there's Bishop F5
the symmetrical line there's the
conservative line with E6 there's G6 and
there's A6 A6 is a totally sensible move
it prevents Knight B5 which is one of
the main ideas of the jabala London
and we respond with the sort of
pedestrian E3
and here we know that black can
developed the bishop to F5 black and
play C5 yeah the hyper modernists are
are all we're all left out of the room
when they suggested that Knight C3 is a
move E6 is also
a totally legitimate possibility
and now we continue developing our
pieces in again relatively mundane in
fashion there is a very interesting
sideline here you can play the media G4
exploiting the fact that the bishop is
now closed off and G4 is not defended
but we're going to play this in uh
strictly positional fashion
and we're going to
start with the move Bishop D3
yeah this guy has a really really good
rapid rapid record I think he's won
every game he's played but we'll do our
best Bishop D6 so already we are
confronted with the Dilemma we
essentially have three options one of
which we can rule out I don't like the
possibility of Bishop takes D6 because
it allows black to play C takes D6 and
establish a Central Pawn Mass
we can play Bishop G3 and most of you
know that Bishop G3 is a commonly
accepted way to play in such a position
but if you've paid attention to my
previous Speed Run game in the jibaba
you might remember that there is nothing
to be afraid of in the bishop takes F4
he takes F4 Pawn structure we can
continue developing normally
because after Bishop F4 ef4 yes the
f-pawns are doubled but your control
over the center increases you get this
you can think of it almost as a reverse
marozzi bind
uh we bind on the E5 square and this is
absolutely nothing to be afraid of
black castles we can Castle ourselves
and you very often get a standoff in
this line where both sides kind of
maneuver around the two Bishops which
are staring at each other but of course
you know Bishop takes F4 for black is
fine especially if it's followed up by a
timely C5 striking at the center and
uh essentially removing one of the two
pawns that create the bind Black Goes B6
yeah and now we establish a Pillsbury
Knight so just like in the regular
London and the jababa London whites play
very frequently revolves around
establishing a knight on E5
and putting the 995 does a couple of
things the Knight is just inherently a
very good piece but in addition we
create a pathway for one of our other
pieces all of a sudden we can already
create
pretty decent attacking chances against
blacksing at least
at least if black misplays this the way
our opponent is playing this is fine
but this is an idea you have to know if
you're a London player what are we
maneuvering into what Square are we
maneuvering it
yeah Queen F3 we start with the move
Queen F3
and from F3 the queen can swing either
to G3 to x-ray the Jeep on or more
prominently to H3 in order to create big
time pressure against the H7 Pawn now H7
is protected by the Knight but the
Knight on F6 is far from an invulnerable
piece knight B to D7 by our opponent
good play
very good play let let's see
yeah this guy is a very very good record
26 and two oh
okay hopefully it's not Carlson
the big question here is Queen G3 or
queen H3 yeah I like Queen H3 because it
is more
uh there's more meat on the bone
with this move because we are actually
pressuring upon that if we win results
in immediate Checkmate and we are
inducing a weakening move which our
opponent has just played the move G6
creates
uh rather prominent holes on the king
side on H6 and on G5 which we can try to
exploit with further maneuvering play
how are we going to try
to exploit Black's
kingside weaknesses give me a second to
think about it
I have a couple of ideas
but I know this guy is very serious so
I'm going to try to play as objectively
as possible
yeah the interesting thing is I would
love to play Bishop H6 and F4
but after Bishop H6 I'm worried about
the exchange sacrifice Knight takes C5
black gets a ton of compensation there
uh for the exchange so I don't want to
move the bishop away from F4 unless we
move it to G5 which is actually a viable
continuation Bishop G5 sacrificing a
Pawn on E5 and then pushing the pawn up
to F4 in that line we're banking
everything on the pin against the Knight
also a little bit too speculative
what other moves can we propose well
we can think about the move Queen H6 but
that seems a little bit aimless and I'm
pretty sure that the queen can be easily
chased out of H6
we can also remove our knight from E5
and basically say well the Knight has
done its job now we're gonna head to G5
to pressure
uh the H7 Pawn again
hmm
okay I know what I like
let's play a positional move
that again if you're experiencing the
jababa London you know about this idea
you move the Knight away from C3 then
you always try to transpose this into a
traditional London by pushing the pawn
up to C3 which is of course a much
healthier Central Pawn formation than
having the Knight on C3 that is the main
drawback of the jabalanda that Knight on
C3 blocks the C pawn and in many cases
allows black to harass the D4 Pawn via
C7 C5
so we're making surface level
improvements to our Pawn structure you
might ask well what about the 992 what
are we going to do with it I don't know
yet maybe we'll move the bishop away and
make space for it on F4 maybe we'll
maneuver it to G3 although that's pretty
unlikely I don't know what it'll be
doing on G3 yeah the Knight is going to
be a flaw in our position that we are
going to try to address later on
our last move was Knight C3 to E2
I would definitely guess that this is
not the top engine move but I think it's
it's simple and practical
it's simple and practical
all right
we are waiting for
our opponent's response to this move
what I'm worried about in this position
I'm worried about one move in particular
which is Knight H5
I am a little bit concerned about the
move Knight H5 because it targets our
Bishop and again if we play Bishop H6
which a lot of you are probably thinking
why not Bishop page six black has this
annoying exchange sacrifice 95 d e
Bishop E5 we take on f8 black takes back
and for the exchange black has it a pawn
and a big big time Pawn mass in the
center black will play C5 and E5 and
I'll show this after the game
uh that line seems pretty unappetizing
to me
so after Knight H5 we can choose to
ignore and we can just continue on with
our plan we can play C3
and of course then we are intending to
meet Knight takes out four once again
with e takes F4
and that H5 is on the board and probably
that is the most practical continuation
I think the most practical continuation
here is just to play C3
and to continue with our initial idea
and if black wants to trade then we take
back with a pawn and once again then we
have a pure Pillsbury Knight on E5 which
is a very very strong piece
so I think this is totally fine for
white
F5 okay that I did not expect
that I did not expect
hmm
yeah I didn't expect it because it it I
mean it weakens or it seems to weaken
the king side but now that I look at it
more carefully I think this is actually
a very strong move
okay so why is this a strong move it
basically puts a blanket over the entire
King side it blocks my Bishop it blocks
my queen it clamps down on White's King
side pieces
and it makes the whole situation on the
king side rather claustrophobic
so because it's so claustrophobic it
might be a good opportunity for us to
just trade a bunch of pieces Knight 67
then maybe we can reshuffle our Bishop
to H6 and bring the other Knight to F4
that would be an interesting idea
uh G4 I think is a little bit too risky
after Knight takes F4 I think creating
these King side weaknesses is it's too
much I think G4 my intuition is kind of
rejecting
hmm
well Bishop page six again he's got the
exchange sacrifice
okay let's go for it let's play Knight
takes D7 I hate to trade
you know it tears my heart out to trade
a knight like that
but it also unburdens our position
allows more Mobility for the bishop
so
we're gonna go Bishop H6
We're Not Gonna trade the Bishops again
I didn't want to trade the dark squared
Bishop Bishops because after C takes D6
we're helping black establish better
control of the center Rook F7
and now I think it's a perfect
opportunity for Knight F4 we've solved
the problem of the night the problem is
that our opponent is going to play
Knight F6 would be my guess
and from F6 the Knight is aiming for G4
and potentially for E4 so what move
naturally comes to mind after Knight F6
yeah F3 F3 is more or less a no-brainer
we have to try to restrict the Knight on
F6 the problem is that black can now
Counter-Strike in the center with E5 and
E5 basically forces us to give up our D4
Pawn not give up as in sacrifice give up
as in trade
uh because moving the knight from F4
would make very little sense we just
made all this effort to put our Knight
on F4 now moving it away be kind of
weird
so let's take it
now the situation has changed our Pawn
is no longer on D4 mostly that's a bad
thing but there is one uh good byproduct
of that what is the good thing that's
that's come up that we can try to
exploit that good thing with our next
move
well the the D file opens up and later
on down the line we can try to put
pressure on the D5 Pawn
and so I think it's natural to bring the
Rook into the game Rook a D1 then maybe
we can move the bishop away from D3
maybe we can play Bishop C2
and potentially we can maneuver the
bishop to B3
and just put light pressure on the D5
Pawn nothing major the D5 Pawn is
incredibly well protected but we can try
to make black a little bit uncomfortable
especially if black plays C5 which I
don't think he will the problem with the
move C5 here is that black forfeits the
opportunity to secure the D5 Pawn with
C6 pawns don't go backwards but black
also probably won't play C6 too quickly
because that closes out the bishop
completely
so our next move
is very likely to be Bishop C2
we also have a store of you know small
improving moves like King H1 Queen H4
like if we have the time for that we'll
go for it rookie 8 is a great move
bringing the Rook into the game
um
I'm slightly worried
that the E3 Pawn is a serious weakness
now one tactical observation that I'm
gonna make here
is that in most cases Rook takes E3
is not really a possibility because it
runs into tactics along this diagonal
like Knight takes G6 could be a very
effective answer to Rook take C3
so I'm not
terrified of losing our E3 Pawn With
that being said it might be a good idea
for us to shift our Rook to E1 just for
over protection's sake
I think we should start with Bishop C2
though this seems like the most flexible
move
we are opening up a channel a line of
negotiation between the rook and the
Queen and our opponent drops the queen
back
but as I just pointed out I think this
offers us a nice opportunity to complete
the maneuver and press down on the D5
pawn bishop B3 makes perfect sense here
Bishop G5 also makes a lot of sense by
the way with the idea of taking the
Knight and taking the pawn
so from a certain point of view Bishop
G5 might be even more flexible but
yeah we're gonna go with our planet
Bishop B3 we maybe we can play Bishop G5
on the next move
okay C6 now that is a pretty serious
concession
that is the pretty serious concession it
weakens Black's position it closes the
bishop I like that we've managed to
induce C4 let's keep the ball rolling
here
it feels natural to me now to play the
move Bishop G5 I don't know exactly why
but maybe putting a little bit more
pressure on the Knight
is is going to put more strain on
Black's position overall so we can play
rookie one but I like to move Bishop G5
what I also like about this move is that
it discourages black from doubling on
the e-file why does it discourage black
because doubling an e-file runs into the
pin along
this diagonal we can follow up with
Queen H4 attacking the Knight directly
so Bishop G5 is just one of those slow
moves where we're trying to increase our
general control over the position make
our opponent a little bit more
uncomfortable
okay I also wasn't expecting that that's
a big concession because Black's dark
squares are incredibly weak here
so it's not a given that we should
recapture with the bishop there is a
case to be made for taking back with a
pawn the drawback of taking with the
pawn is very obvious right well first of
all we move upon from the center second
of all the bishop on G5 is essentially
locked in prison it can't go back
but maybe it doesn't need to go back
right G5 is a phenomenal Square
for the bishop and maybe he can just
chill on G5 for the rest of the game
basically
um I quite like the look of e takes F4
actually I like both moves I think white
is better in both cases Bishop takes F4
is the conventional move
it's the safe move
but there's just something Charming
about e takes F4 maybe it'll backfire
terribly
maybe it'll backfire terribly let me
think about this for a second skimmy it
give me a moment
I really don't know
I really really don't know I'm gonna
take with the bishop though let's be
conservative this game but we're playing
a very strong opponent
after the game we'll investigate Pawn
takes
my intuition is that pawn takes is a
much better move than it looks like but
Bishop takes is is sort of you know
straight laced and we're gonna play
straight lay style in this game
and probably regret it once we lose
it's not about being a scaredy cat it's
not like a it's not a he takes F4 is not
a sacrifice you know it's not like you
you know
you demonstrate your bravery by playing
that move it's just a purely positional
question I
it's not really about even taking a risk
Queen E6 is good
yeah okay Rook fe1 makes a lot of sense
here
let's solidify our Pawn
okay
Knight H5 yeah so of course we shouldn't
give away our Bishop is our only and
Main asset the only question is should
we play Bishop G5 or should we play
Bishop H6 Bishop G5
obviously looks a lot more natural
but the good thing about Bishop H6 is
that it it essentially holds the king
down
and It prepares this move E4
hmm another very difficult dilemma here
what ultimately sways me
no I don't know what sways me Bishop G5
is interesting Bishop H6 is interesting
let's go to H6 let's go to H6
what I like about yeah what does sway me
is that it it keeps the King on the
eighth rank
so we open up the possibility of some E4
ideas if we can open up the center the
fact that Black's King is on stuck on a
back rank there's like back rank threats
that could be valuable C5
okay
E4 looks really good to me
but I haven't really investigated it
carefully
I really like the look of E4 just blast
open the center because we have the
bishop pair we have better control over
the position in general
right
I think it's time for a pawn break
I think it's time for a pawn break
there's also some variations to
calculate here which I've kind of done
yeah F takes E4 I thought was bad
so now what we do is we take the queen
we have to
and here we need to spend a couple of
moments
because Rook takes C4 is a possibility
Bishop takes D5 is a possibility
even Rook takes C5 is a possibility
I think we're winning if we find the
right approach
so let me pause here to reflect for a
moment
so F takes E4
he probably goes work fe7
don't like it ah but then we go Rook F1
let me go Rook F1
looks pretty good actually
Rook takes C4 Rook takes E4 F takes E4
C4 we have Bishop takes C4
oh
gosh it's so hard to make this decision
well I'll talk after the game why this
is so difficult
I'm trying to calculate my way out of
this
I really like the look of Rook takes D5
actually
but then he takes takes rookie five
I have a feeling fe4 is the best move
I just have an intuition that it's the
best move because it keeps the most
amount of pieces on the board
it keeps the maximum amount of pieces on
the board
and that's what we basically have to try
to do here
okay let's go FV
let's go Fe
E Yeah and C4 I thought was a blunder
C4 I think is a blunder who can tell me
why
I think C4 is a mistake
who can tell me why
actually there's many reasons this is a
really bad move and it's impulsive yeah
Bishop takes C4 is the simplest move
that's the one we're gonna play even e
takes D5 I think works in exactly the
same way rookie one rookie one and
you're threatening made on E8
let me just make sure that Bishop takes
C4 is the best move because we're if we
win this game this guy is good this will
be a a pretty nice win
okay Bishop C4 rookie seven again we can
go Rook F1 and okay our opponent just
resigns
our opponent just resigns
trip C4 the game is over
after Bishop C4 the game is over
let's take a look at it it's
surprisingly short game 27 moves
and that was
a tremendous amount of complexity
for a game that short there were tons of
decisions we had to make and
I'm pretty happy with how we made them
okay so jabala London Bishop F4 you if
you want a a more basic introduction to
this opening you can look at my previous
jababa London speedrun video uh which
was around the time we were 1900. and
yeah A6 is considered to be one of the
most reputable responses to the jubaba
E3 and E6 totally normal
Bishop D3 Bishop D6 of course black can
also play the immediate C5 you can take
a look at this yourself if you want a
line with black against probably Bishop
D6 is is fine although I think I think
C5 is a little bit more accurate after
Bishop D6 the engine starts giving a a
small Edge for white so maybe this
doesn't equalize completely essentially
if you're playing this line
um Gary I'll talk about that line
afterwards if you're playing this line
then it makes sense to play without A6
right E6 saves the tempo of course after
E6 there is Knight B5 and perhaps this
is why black played A6 but the tempo was
spent in a questionable way
so castles castles B6 yeah and now we
play in very traditional fashion 95
Queen F3 this is all very
straightforward and bd7
I still see a game in the database here
and queen H3
makes perfect sense to me
G6
and this is sort of the first critical
position I'm not totally happy with the
decision I ended up making I would be
very curious to see what the engine
recommends here I can sense that white
is better
um okay so I turned the engine on by the
way full disclosure yeah I see what the
move is yeah 92 is definitely a mistake
after Knight H5 we lose all of our
advantage
or maybe not all of it maybe white is
still a tad bit better but it's it's
definitely inaccurate
um
okay so before we get there this is an
interesting position
if black plays Knight E4 and this is a
very common way to try to address the
Knight on E5 you you put a knight on the
equivalent Square here white simply has
F3 that's the main calling card of
putting the queen on H3 it's to meet 94
with F3 and obviously the Knight just
has to return to F6 which is a
disastrous loss of tempo after 90 F6 we
already have the devastating move Bishop
G5 threatening to take one night then
the other night and then made him on H7
if H6 we take on D7 we take on F6 and we
take on H6 so black cannot afford to
just give up to Tempe here Bishop G5 is
a very serious threat in this position
so from that perspective G6 makes sense
H6 would have also made a lot of sense
but here black would have had to reckon
with the bishop sacrifice on H6 in my
experience in these positions the
sacrifice usually works
and one of the main reasons that it
works is that if black takes twice on E5
we drop our Queen back to G5 at a
minimum and we can win the bishop back
probably F4 wins even faster because
this real Clift is totally devastating
so
the Sacramento H6 looks very very strong
here
um you want to hear something crazy
after Bishop takes E5
I I'm looking at the engine eval D takes
E5 is plus one but there is a move here
that's plus four and it's absolutely
amazing I'll let you guys try to guess
if you're watching this on YouTube pause
the video try to guess the right move
it's logical it makes logical sense but
it's still a pretty awesome move F4 yeah
very good F4
F4 what is the idea why are you sending
the bishop back now you sack on G7
and the idea shines through but not just
yet most people would play Rook F3 here
Rook F3 loses the game after Rook G8 the
king escapes via f8
so what is the technique for I'm not
allowing that you
use your queen to Shepherd Black's King
uh onto a more vulnerable Square you
start with a check now it's zigzag time
notice that the role of the bishop
preventing Knight H7 continuing the
zigzag finishing the zigzag and now we
play Rook F3 and the King cannot Escape
through f8 because the queen controls it
beautiful sequence is that a beautiful
sequence
first you play up let me do that again
first you play F you sack on H6
then you do not recapture the Knight
then you sack on G7 you zigzag all the
way to H6 and you lift The Rook up with
mate
just an amazing line
uh so for that reason G6 is a very
sensible move so the engine move here is
pure prophylaxis
um I've made this point
many times before that when you hear the
term engine move right a move that
you don't understand it's generally
because the move prevents something and
that something might be a very subtle
idea in this case it's not a subtle idea
black wants to play Knight H5 he's not
making any bones about that Knight H5 is
a big positional threat we decided to
allow it uh and we took the hit but
white does it have to take the hit the
move is not G4 G4 is too weakening G4
could be met with Knight E4
and and notice how you've weakened all
these dark squares too many weaknesses
around your king a much more graceful
prophylactic move is just Bishop drops
back to E2 stopping Knight H5 that way
this is the top move
uh a valuable thing to know is that in
these types of positions C5 is almost
never possible because of this very
simple tactic Knight F7 and Bishop D6
the bishop on D6 is only defended by the
pawn so the Knight on D7 obstructs the
queen black has a hard time finding a
move here white is totally dominating
all of the key squares
Black's King side is sort of in shambles
white is better it's plus plus 0.5 or so
yeah the top move here is 98. that's not
the easiest move to play then we can
bring our Rook into the game
and if black okay black can't even play
F6 because he drops the pawn so
this is a this is a tricky position for
black to navigate notice how one
prophylactic move like that would have
really changed the nature of the
position I played 92 after Knight H5
Blackberry is a big side relief C3
yeah so F5 I didn't expect at all and in
retrospect I think this might be an
inaccuracy I think the problem with that
five is that it creates tons of holes on
the king side that black didn't really
need to create
I think black should have just taken on
F4
he takes F4 and now a very instructive
moment let's say you're playing Black
here big question do you take on E5 or
not
what's the answer think about that for a
second do we take on E5 or not
I like it when the crowd is divided
because that tells me there's an
instructive point to be made
so the answer is no
at least in my opinion I don't think it
loses again when I say no does it lose
the game no
but this structure you have to be very
very careful about because white has a
devastating plan in these types of
positions that comes really quickly and
it's incredibly destructive that plan is
to play F4 G4 and F5 and smash through
on the king side with unbelievable Force
notice that black doesn't really have
counter play on the other side of the
board this bishop is just a lame duck
uh and and we have an amazingly
well-defended Pawn structure F4 F4
let's say black plays C5 which is like a
typical response right
then we play G4
FCD we can play CD we can even play
Knight takes D4 probably even better
because we can we attack the
E6 Pawn F5 is coming next and Black's
King side is is just totally falling
apart
totally falling apart
um
let me see if I can find some games with
this plan in action
uh this is a very very widespread
ubiquitous plan
so this is almashay against vavra
al-mashu later became a very strong GM
from Hungary he was Hungarian number one
so we have a French right and this
structure originates mostly out of the
French which makes a lot of sense right
literally in the French you get the
structure out of the opening so watch
what Alma she does here he goes Knight
G5
H6 Queen H5 attacking F7 and inducing G6
notice that Queen drops back
the night is just chilling on G5 it
doesn't have to move Bishop is deployed
to A3 black plays A5 and watch what Alma
she does here
Black's structure looks very very solid
Bang
Bang
now Rook a B1
attacking B6 inducing Knight B5 you take
on E7 to force the king out and F5
anyway
F5 anyway because H takes G5 runs into
F6 winning the rook and then winning the
Knight on B5 later
if black tries to get away by sacking an
exchange you're not just stacking an
exchange you're also losing your knight
at the end of the line that's why white
played Rook B1
so blackish is getting totally destroyed
here he tried Knight takes C3
but after the app file is open and the B
file is open there's too many things to
defend Rook comes to F6
takes on E6 and now the final move the
game is Queen B2 the king is toast after
Rook B6 Queen B6 and so black resigned
in that position
post stick thank you for the prime not
the not the best example I could have
showed but you know it's the best I
could find in 10 seconds let's go back
to the speedrun game hopefully you
have added a new plan to your sort of
mental database which is what you have
to do uh is is keep learning new
structures and the typical plants in
those structures
okay
so for that reason in this position you
do not want to take on E5 and I would
advocate for a move like C5
now you might say well wait a second
doesn't white have the same plan here
can't white play G4 and then F5 it ain't
that easy with this Knight still sitting
on E5 let's make a random move F5 at
this point is just a terrible move
because you give up the pawn and White's
not getting anywhere with a king-site
attack so for that reason you want to
keep the Knight alive on E5
does that make sense so I think this
position is about equal you know black
has the two Bishops black has some
pressure in the center white has I would
prefer white we have a nice Knight we
have a very safe position but it's hard
for either side here to really make a
lot of progress
so F5 I think is a step in the wrong
direction
we decided to meet it by taking on D7
another important moment occurred here
another important moment occurred here
Queen takes D7 is not forced black has a
second option to take on F4 first should
he have done that I think the answer is
yes I think giving us the opportunity to
conserve our dark squared Bishop one
could argue is what won us the game that
Bishop landed on H6 at the end and it is
because it kept the king under lock and
key that black suffered when the Center
opened up
so I I actually think black should have
taken on F4 I don't know what we would
have taken back with
probably the pawn again leading to an
important structure
where these pawns are holding back the
E6 Pawn I call this the bobbining
structure
I call this the buffing structure a
situation where the opposing side has a
backward Pawn
and we have one or two pawns that are
holding it back preventing it from
moving and of course the plan uh is to
pile up the pressure on the E6 Pawn but
it's hard for us to do that because this
Knight is in the way and to move the
Knight you have to defend F4 and black
can easily defend E6 50 different ways
black and play freaking rookie Aid and
Bishop C8 and Rook F6 nonetheless uh
this is an important plan to be aware of
since we're on the topic let me show you
why I call it the buffing plan there's a
famous game that's shown to a lot of
Russian School boys
bavanick 16 year old bavanick against
Holland cabbage I might have shown this
on stream before
so bhavanick faces a strong Soviet
master
so you have a pretty regular accelerated
Dragon position
and in this position Bob benick
initiates a series of traits he plays
Knight D5
there's a trade on D5 black is like just
trade everything and Strikes with B5
now what similarity can you notice
between the speedrun game in this
position well it's the fact that black
has this E7 Pawn that is held back by
the pawn on D5 and so Bob and it carries
out a very textbook plan that involves
piling up with everything that he's got
on the e-file and of course combining
that with pressure on the queen side
first you give a check so he decides to
trade on B5 in order to give himself a
pawn majority on the queen side that
pawn majority is ultimately going to win
him the game
ultimately it's going to win him the
game
now he goes rookie one rookie three
eight four combining Queen side and King
side plate double on the E file and tie
black down
keep the pawn rolling B4 is a great move
what is his idea on Queen takes A4 it's
not Rook takes E7
it's to play Rook A1
and Bishop F1 winning the bishop on A6
notice how he uses tactics to make stuff
work
Bishop B7 B5
B6 so he's tied black down
against the epon now he makes progress
on the queen side he trades off Black's
only active piece the other Rook you
can't take on A5 because Rook C7 wins
the bishop so he trades off Black's last
remaining active piece black tries to
get the Rook to the CFO no no no no get
back to defending the e-pawn I'm the one
who's gonna get control of the C file
Rook C8 is forced and now the decisive
combination you trade it and who can
find essentially the what should have
been the final move of the game black
played on for a few more moves but this
should have been the final move of the
game beautiful little combination
check
the weaponized Queen trade if black
doesn't take then we take and go B7
promoting if black does take that opens
up the bishop which has been patiently
waiting by the way for the entire game
to have its moment in the sun now it has
its moment in the sun supporting B7
and
black resigned here the a pawn literally
promotes
actually one of my favorite kind of
textbook positional classic games that
is not shown enough a good illustration
of working against weak Pawns
hope you enjoyed it uh bobbin against
Holland Kevin you could take down the
names opponents names and you could look
at it yourself later you could just
Google it
what differentiates the speedrun
position from the Batman positions well
there's confounding factors right
there's a weakness that white has which
is F4
black has a lot more defensive Machinery
at his disposal and so for that position
for that reason I think White's edge
here is
not insignificant but pretty small by
the way white also has this interesting
idea and the engine gives this idea of
moving the king to H1 and then
maneuvering the Knight to E5 there's a
beautiful juicy Square on E5 we can try
to get our Knight there white is better
here but the advantage is limited I
think after Queen D7 Bishop H6 Black's
position is already very very unpleasant
Knight F4 is very nice we get our Knight
to a good Square
now compare this position
compare this position
with uh you know this position it's
similar pod structure but there we have
a bishop rather than a knight
and the bishop does a great job
disrupting the coordination of Black's
pieces and here it's much easier to get
our Rooks doubled much faster
so black is in trouble in this position
Knight F6 makes sense and now F3 to
restrict the Knight E5 makes sense again
takes takes Rook 81 bringing the Rook
into the game and adapting to the new
set of circumstances the center has
opened we now have to reorient our
pieces appropriately
rookie E8
isn't our Bishop blocked well it's the
sort of you know Norwegian prison
situation where yeah the bishop is
confined
uh to two squares
but its influence is still tremendous
it's like Jean-Paul morat you know he's
confined to his bathtub but he's still
dictating the course of the French
Revolution
the bishop is controlling f8 and it's
defending the F Pawn so we don't have to
worry about this and if we later play G4
then the bishop is going to be a
participant in the attack
you should read about them if you don't
know kind of a cool story
Rook ae1
and rookie three and rookie one is
coming and the bishop is is doing its
part
Knight F6 F3
so E5 d-e-d-e we gotta Rook into the
game rookie eight
and Bishop C2 our new plan is to put
pressure slash attack the D5 pawn and we
did that with the move Bishop B3 C6 is a
serious concession and now we drop the
other Bishop back to put pressure on the
Knight
I think Bishop takes F4 is nearly the
decisive mistake yeah I was right he
takes that four is the best move
we should have gone for this this or at
least on a low depth okay what we can
say is it's not a bad move now it's
changing its mind and saying Bishop F4
is better
but they're approximately equivalent
uh yeah [ __ ] was Charlotte
see I remember something from school
um the point of he takes F4 is to open
up the e-file obviously
why is white the one who benefits from
opening up the e-file even though black
is already the one with the Rook on E8
well the reason is that we're gonna play
Rook fe1 on the next move let's make a
random move by white by black
and this is where the bishop on G5 comes
in Black cannot contest the E file with
Rook at V7 because he drops the Knight
now you could say oh no problem let's
just move the Knight first well if you
move the Knight then you still can't go
rookie seven because now the bishop is
controlling that square let's make
another random move by black how can
white fight for control of the e-file
well we have a beautiful defended Square
on E5 we can play rookie five and Rook D
E1 and we're starting to encircle
Black's pieces does that make sense so
ef4 is a very deep move and it would
have been an interesting try but we took
with the bishop okay Queen E6 Rook fe1
Knight H5 and Bishop back to H6 creating
the conditions that make E4 successful
okay
C5
and E4 strike striking in the center now
this is where black made the actual
decisive mistake F takes A4 just loses
the game and black played too quickly
it turns out that after C4 black is
actually still all right I will be
totally honest I kind of forgot that
after e takes D5 black s Queen takes E1
check
and the interesting thing is that this
position still looks winning for white
this position still looks winning for
right why does it look winning for white
because the Rook is hanging and if black
moves The Rook we take on C4 what do we
have for the two Rooks we have a queen
we have these two pawns and we're
basically gonna go D6 on the next move
and you know make make kimbap out of
Black's position but there is a subtlety
that I missed after King F2 black has a
winning move who can find it pause the
video if you're watching on YouTube find
Black's winning move these things happen
out of nowhere C takes B3 exactly
C takes B3
and after King A1 ba2 you know White's
pieces are all on the other side of the
board black promotes such a frustrating
and such a coincidence if the pawn is on
A3 this wouldn't work
my chest is such a crazy so white has to
take but now Black Goes Rook at V7 with
Checkmate on top of everything else
um so for this reason after C4 we would
have had to drop our Bishop back to C2
I think practically speaking white is
still much better
and again just so everybody's on the
same page what makes Black's position so
difficult here is that he cannot take on
e4
because black gets mated that's
partially mostly why we put the bishop
on H6 in order to make this impossible
for black
uh but black black has a hard time
finding a move here because now we're
threatening to take one of these Pawns
probably black has to play d e f e and
now the engine gives some weird move
Knight G7 that's not an easy move to
play Knight F6 is a little bit more
human but now we push the pawn up to E5
Knight G4 Bishop F4 and this is of
course a lot more palatable for black
than the game continuation but still
we're gonna move our Queen away from H3
then we're gonna push the pawn to H3 and
the knight's gonna have problems
positions like these are very very hard
to handle for humans
positions with a lot of weak squares and
a weak color complex notice that all of
Black's dark squares are suffering
because of the absence of a dark squirt
Bishop
so let's just confirm that I made the
right decision in this position I did F
takes C4 is the best move
so what was I you know agonizing over I
had three candidate moves the four
candidate moves there's Bishop D5
there's Rook takes D5 which is
interesting there's fe4 and there's Rook
takes E4 let me tell you exactly why I
ruled out the other three
Rook takes D5 I almost went for because
it's a sexy move it looks sleek and the
idea is that after Bishop 55 Bishop D5
rookie five we have what looks like a
beautiful move wet has a rook takes E4
forcing a transition
into a knight versus Bishop end game
because Rook D5 gets mated I was
attracted to this but let's keep
calculating after rookie 4 fv4 looks
like everything's in order Black's King
is paralyzed everything's great but
Knight F6 is an illusion shattering move
it attacks the bishop you if you want
you can drop the bishop back but you
can't actually attack The Rook so black
is more than fine with this arrangement
and if you take then the E4 Pawn is now
a Sitting Duck we literally white is not
better anymore and here white is
probably worse because Black's King is
closer to the center
so this is the line that reject that
explains why I rejected Rook D5
um I I mean I saw up to Knight F6 I saw
up to Knight F6 and I stopped there
Bishop takes D5 is better than Rook
takes D5 but after takes takes takes
black has Rook fee seven I thought
and the best that white can do is a pawn
up end game which I wasn't totally
convinced by
uh Rook d8 there's rookie eight that's
the reason black plays rookie seven I
stopped calculating here the engine
gives rookie 4 rookie 4 fe4
and apparently after rookie four there's
this move Rook D6 skewering the pawns
along the sixth rank it's plus 1.5 white
is better but it's just a pawn
it's just a pawn
um
so the last move that I thought about is
Rook takes C4 this move was the second
best and I almost played it
Rook takes E4 F takes E4 C4 same thing
as in the game white has Bishop takes E4
so I think this would have been very
very similar Rook takes E4 the engine
gives Rook F to E7
which is the additional resource that
black would not have had after F take C4
takes takes takes takes and why this up
of Pawn for no compensation and Black's
King is in trouble because it's confined
to its quarters
so Rook E4 would have been good we
played the simple move and after C4
black resigned Bishop C4 is game over we
just win all the Pawns
um the only move to stay in the game
according to the engine was something
weird Rook D7
and now I was planning Rook F1 in fact I
was expecting Rook fe7 but Rook F1 is a
Crusher because it threatens made on f8
and moves The Rook away from the e-file
what effect does that have well it makes
e takes D5 possible in this position 85
would have been impossible because this
is a check
if this weren't to check white would
have D6
yeah unfortunately I couldn't play the
move black resign beforehand but Rook
fe7 Rook F1 threatens mate and black is
getting torn apart here I mean we're
just like
we're just destroying black here here
this is this is the position plays
itself at this point
so that's why I spent
you know a hefty amount of time on FBI
was calculating all of this
and this this basically just finishes
the game
and that's that 27 moves black resign
after C4 again we would have played
Bishop C4 taking is impossible because
of mate
in two
and if black doesn't take then on the
next move we take on D5 we're two pawns
up and we're still mating the King by
getting a rook to E8
yeah very pretty and and I think a very
very high quality game I'm pretty happy
with my decision making
the move I'm not happy with is 92 I at
least I chose the right Square
Bishop E2 prophylaxis in critical
moments and for our opponent his mistake
was first of all to leave the bishop
Alive Black had two opportunities to
take the bishop out of the game right
here and even here black could have
played Knight takes F4 get giving the
bishop a new lease on life is really
what lost black the game
and the second thing I'd say is black
played very well in this stretch
perhaps giving up the bishop is another
inaccuracy not perhaps it definitely is
black should play for example Knight D7
Knight C5 the position still close to
equal
although white plays C4 and this is
unpleasant for sure practically speaking
uh and then the decisive mistake the
mistake that actually lost the game was
Fe after C4 black is still very much in
the game especially if he's careful
you suggested King H1 as a Canada move
why was that the king H1 that I
mentioned was was here
King G1 to H1 or is that the one you're
talking about
yeah it's to pave the way it's to pave
the way for the maneuver of the Knight
to E5 and the interesting thing that I
could do is I could I could show you a
million games with this exact maneuver
let me see if I can find it
Oh wrong game Sorry not this one I mean
in this one white white does this so
This maneuver has been known since like
the 1800s King H1 Knight G1
Knight F3 and eventually the Knight gets
to E5 here is another game where both
sides do the same thing
Rubenstein of course incredibly strong
so white plays King H1
black plays 94. 1 King h a knight G1
Knight G8
Knight F3 Knight F6 of course Black's
idea is different from White's Black's
idea is to replace one of the knights
with the other night
but eventually black white got the
better of Akiba Rubenstein Bishop C1
opening up the pathway for The Rook to
H3 oh this is really cool okay he went
back to F3 though
and eventually he just created Total
wow what a game
this is awesome deep look at the final
combination look at what he did here
Bishop B1 Queen C3 creating a battery
Bishop A2 which is probably unnecessary
but still take stakes in D5 cool stuff
so since this King H1 Knight G1 maneuver
is very common when you have a Wiki five
squared axis My Hope of these games
isn't to belabor the point it's to make
sure that you have an easier time
remembering you know these various ideas
so on that note folks I think we're
gonna end the speedrun thank you for
watching and I'll be back
with more chess tomorrow bye
[Music]